tiger woods suffered serious but
non-life-threatening injuries after a
violent car crash near los
angeles it was my understanding that it
serious injuries to both lakes
the los angeles county sheriff's
department said it was a single car
rollover collision woods was the sole
occupant of the suv
no skid marks no braking so apparently
the first contact was with the center
median
and from there then crossed into the
opposing lane of traffic
hit the curb hit a tree and there was
several
rollovers during that process the
vehicle wound up lying on its side at
the bottom of the shallow ravine
one look at the severe damage to the
front of the suv
shows how violent the accident was the
outcome could certainly have been worse
the front end was totally destroyed the
bumpers everything was destroyed
airbags deployed all of that and however
thankfully the interior was more or less
intact which kind of gave him
the cushion to survive what's otherwise
would have been a fatal crash
sheriff's deputies who pried woods loose
from the wreck say
he was wearing seat belts and that he
was conscious
lucid and able to speak with his
rescuers
authorities say there was no evidence
woods was impaired by alcohol or
drugs the 45 year old golf legend was
transported to a nearby hospital
and underwent surgery tiger woods is
unquestionably one of the greatest
golfers of
all time he won 15 major championships
including five masters tournaments
three british opens four pga
championships and
more as a person of color who dominated
what had been an overwhelmingly white
sport he shattered barriers and expanded
horizons for other athletes
inspiring many fans young and old tiger
it was said
made golf cool woods has had his share
of difficulties and embarrassments
including a messy divorce and the
disclosure of multiple
marital infidelities it's still not
known whether woods will play golf
professionally again
after tuesday's crash police say it may
take days
or weeks before they determine the cause
of the accident
rob reynolds al jazeera los angeles